[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers hallo
und guten abend hinein was russlands
präsident putin davor fast drei monaten
los trat hat eine ganze reihe von folgen
die er selbst nicht gewollt haben kann
die nato entwickelt plötzlich eine
enorme anziehungskraft
finnlands parlament entscheidet sich
heute für einen beitritt die schweden
haben das bereits gestern getan eine
historische entwicklung die die
allermeisten vor drei monaten noch für
hirngespinste gehalten hätten gleich
mehr dazu erst gucken wir auf die
militärische lage und auch da ist
einiges in bewegung
nach monaten der russischen belagerung
haben mehr als 260 ukrainische kämpfer
im stahlwerk aufgegeben darunter auch
soldaten des ultranationalistischen
azoff regiments in dem auch
rechtsradikale kämpfen sie sollen gegen
russische kriegsgefangene ausgetauscht
werden das weitläufige gelände war die
letzte bastion der ukraine in mariupol
der wichtigen hafenstadt die wiese
wichtige hafenstadt ist damit komplett
in russischer hand auf der anderen seite
meldet die ukraine geländegewinne in der
region kharkiv dort sind russische
truppen auf dem rückzug bestätigen auch
westliche geheimdienstquellen und ein
interner lagebericht der bundeswehr
zeigt der russische angriff läuft alles
andere als nach plan wie das konkret vor
ort aussieht dazu jetzt yasin herrlein
und quentin sammer will
der krieg kam sehr plötzlich über sie
hier an der östlichen front das leben
für diese männer spielt sich weitgehend
in kellern ab unter tage
doch von wegducken kann hier keine rede
sein
dreimal hat die russische armee in den
letzten tagen angegriffen mit artillerie
panzern und infanterie dreimal haben sie
zurückgeschlagen
dazwischen bleibt nur warten auf den
nächsten angriff
sämtliche mitglieder dieser einheit der
ukrainischen territorial armee sind
freiwillige viele von ihnen haben
keinerlei militärische ausbildung und
dennoch stehen sie an vorderster front
über ihn befindet sich ein vorort der
stadt ist die auch das tor zum don bass
genannt wird
sie sind viel mehr als wir aber wir sind
ukraine wir befinden uns in unserem land
egal wie gut der feind und seine
soldaten sind sie haben nicht die
unterstützung der menschen hier wie wir
diese einschläge sind das signal wieder
an die arbeit zu gehen
außerhalb dieser mauern ist alles
schusslinie
im norden befinden sich umfangreiche
russische einheiten südlich von ihnen
ihre kameraden der ukrainischen armee
sie müssen die stellung halten damit
diese nicht umzingelt werden
ribéry fällt unsere männer kämpfen jeden
tag weil wir glauben dass alle
demokratischen länder die ganze welt uns
helfen wird und wenn wir moderne waffen
bekommen werden diese mutigen männer die
russische armee komplett zerstören
der weg zurück in die schützenden keller
ist durch artilleriefeuer abgeschnitten
die männer suchen sich einen weg durch
gärten und hinterhöfe und stellen mit
einem mal fest dass nicht alle diesen
ort verlassen haben
eine frau namens natascha weigert sich
ihr haus zu verlassen ganz so als würde
sie das geschützfeuer in unmittelbarer
nähe nicht hören
ich will meinen mann nicht verraten er
liegt hier auf dem friedhof
ich werde ihn nicht zurücklassen
ein letztes mal versuchen die männer sie
zu überreden mit ihnen zu kommen
vergeblich
warum ich habe mich inzwischen daran
gewöhnt geht ihr nur ihr burschen
weiter heftiges feuer
so hörte sich an das bad an der
östlichen front unter einsatz dieser
männer ist in den augen der ukraine das
was getan werden muss um das tor zum don
was fest verschlossen zu halten
unfassbare bilder das waren die bilder
jetzt kommt die analyse wie ist die lage
vor ort was heißt das für die zukunft
dazu ist der ehemalige nato-general egon
ramms bei uns herr general willkommen im
heute-journal
guten receiver beginnen wir vielleicht
sind da können wir uns auch eine karte
dazu angucken das macht das ganze ja mal
so ein bisschen leichter die ukraine wir
sehen hier in orange die russisch
besetzten russisch gehaltenen gebiete in
rot die aktuelle frontlinie und wir
beginnen mal mit aktiv im nordosten
zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine können
denn die russen daselbst minimalziele
überhaupt noch erreichen
also umschlag herum sieht es so aus dass
die russen ihre großen ziele dort nicht
erreichen werden ich habe vorher
zeitweilig schon mal in teilen auch vor
russischen soldaten besetzt und ist
offensichtlich geht es durch die ukraine
fast vollständig wieder frei gekämpft
worden dabei möchte ich den hinweis
geben wir haben den vergangenen tagen
dieses bild gesehen von einer
ukrainischen einheit die bis an die
grenze vorgestoßen ist das sehe ich noch
ein bisschen skeptisch aber trotzdem
muss man sagen dass die ukraine auch
hier aufgrund ihrer großen moral der
unterstützung der bevölkerung
erfolgreich gegen die russen gekämpft
dann gehen wir weiter in den südosten
des landes auch da können wir auf eine
karte schauen mario pohl wir haben
gerade schon erwähnt in der sendung das
stahlwerk die letzte bastion der ukraine
jetzt gefallen welche optionen wenn sie
sich da auch mal auf die karte
konzentrieren heraus ergeben sich denn
jetzt für die russischen angreifer aus
dieser situation
also ich glaube wir müssen das lokale
ziel mario pohl unterscheiden von einem
möglichen strategischen ziel das lokale
ziel war erstmal diese kämpfe um das
stahlwerk zu beenden und auf diese art
und weise den kampf dort einzustellen
das heißt nicht dass der havel von mario
pohl geht's in absehbarer zeit wieder
genutzt werden kann ich gehe davon aus
dass dort noch keine schiffe einlaufen
können zurzeit und b wahrscheinlich auch
dort im hafenbereich minen liegen damit
der hafen im augenblick nicht nutzbar
ist das strategische ziel geht in eine
andere richtung so glaube ich das zu
erkennen es geht darum tatsächlich die
gesamte schwarzmeerküste in den griff zu
kriegen das heißt die weiteren angriffe
dort unten im süden gehen dann richtung
südwesten beziehungsweise in den raum
von odessa um dann praktisch anschluss
an die an die nachbarländer zu gewinnen
ich glaube nicht ich sage das ganz froh
das geht wirklich tatsächlich darum dass
ich das nicht vorhersagen kann ich
glaube nicht dass den russen das
gelingen wird weil ich davon ausgehe
dass auch in diesem bereich der
widerstand gegen die russischen
aggression in gleicher art und weise
fortgesetzt wird noch ein wort zu den
soldaten die aus mario pohl evakuiert
worden sind mit einschließlich der
verwundeten sie gehen in
kriegsgefangenschaft das richtet sich
nach der darin genfer abkommen von 1949
und wenn ich dann höre dass das
duma-abgeordnete gibt die auf einmal
laut sagen den droht die todesstrafe
dann haben offensichtlich mal wieder
russische vertreter die rechtliche
grundlage nämlich interpretiert oder b
sie von erneut an kriegsverbrechen zu
begehen wenn wir auf die gesamtlage
gucken was heißt denn das jetzt für die
länge des krieges kann man da schon ja
an anzeichen sehen
also da ich zur zeit keine rückzugs
bewegungen freiwilligen rückzugs
bewegungen der russen erkennen kann es
sei denn man gruppiert möglicherweise
wieder kräfte um wie wir das vor einigen
wochen erlebt haben von dem raum
nördlich von kiew dann geht der kampf
weiter ich glaube nicht dass die
russische seite das heißt der präsident
und sein verteidigungsminister und seine
soldaten das aufgeben werden das heißt
man sollte sich darauf einrichten dass
wir über monate reden
und dann gucken wir auf die nato auch
ein wichtiges thema heute an diesem tag
sie waren herr als ranghöchster
deutscher nato-general ist denn ein
beitritt von finnland und schweden eine
zeitenwende auch für die nato und was
heißt das konkret für das bündnis
also mit blick auf die beiden länder ist
es erstmal das seitenwände für die
beiden länder ich war oben in diesem
bereich als ausbilder der nato war hoch
wird ausbildungen tätig an denen auch
die finden und die schweden teilgenommen
haben und damals das ist 45 jahre her
gab es auch schwedischer unter
finnischer seite keine absicht indikator
einzutreten oder ein beitrittsgesuch zu
stellen die schweden und die finden
waren damals stolz auf ihre neutralität
und auf ihre unabhängigkeit die einen
schweden 200 jahre alt ist und in
finnland auch schon 80 jahre alt ist von
daher ist das schon wirklich eine
zeitenwende die herbeigeführt worden ist
durch das verhalten von putin und durch
die tatsache dass sie schweden und
finden bedroht fühlen und für die nato
selbst die hat ja wenn wir diese karte
ich weiß nicht ob er nochmal kurz zeigen
können hat die nato dann wenn finnland
und schweden mit dabei wären ja quasi
den gesamten
ostseeraum als binnenmeer sozusagen also
ist ist ja also die ostsee wird damit
endlich wieder boden sicherlich bei
einer gesagt zu einem binnenmeer
weil alle staaten die an die ostsee an
grenzen bis auf den schmalen streifen um
sankt petersburg und kaliningrad
praktisch dann
küstenländer nato mitglieder sind was
die möglichkeiten der zusammenarbeit
dort oben ein deutlich verbessert und
man muss dazu wissen dass es auch schon
vorher eine nordische gemeinschaft
gegeben hat von norwegen bis nach
finnland die sich mit diesem raum
beschäftigt haben und jetzt findet das
dann halt eben künftig wenn der beitritt
vollzogen ist auch möglicherweise gegen
die widerstände von herrn erdogan
vollzogen ist praktisch komplett in den
autoren der ehemalige nato-general egon
ramms auch heute wieder ganz herzlichen
dank für diese analyse heran
herzlichen dank gerne
die nato nord erweiterung also wir haben
es gehört ein echter meilenstein nicht
nur für die menschen in finnland und
schweden auch für die nato selbst und
ein meilenstein dem noch einige steine
im weg liegen interessanterweise aus der
nato selbst der türkische präsident hat
da eine ganz eigene rechnung offen
florian hein jetzt über einen tag an dem
es sich lohnt mal tief ins film archiv
zu steigen
als der junge carl gustaf 1973 könig von
schweden wird steht die nato mitten im
kalten krieg und das land das er fortan
repräsentiert ist neutral und stolz
darauf
fast 50 jahre später ist nur der könig
derselbe geblieben heute darf er der
monarch ohne macht mit dem finnischen
staatspräsidenten an seiner seite einen
satz für die geschichtsbücher sprechen
schweden hat die absicht zur selben zeit
und in übereinstimmung mit finnland der
verteidigungsallianz nato beizutreten
es ist ein tag an dem das wort
historisch so oft fällt wie selten als
die schwedische außenministerin den
beitrittsantrag unterzeichnet oder als
es wenig später ihr finnischer kollege
tut
hier ist der brief für brüssel
hoffentlich geht die post
zwei länder die sich jahrhundertelang
auf ihre eigenen armeen verließen suchen
den schutz der militärallianz sie sollen
ihnen schnell bekommen man nicht nur der
deutschen kanzler deutschland wird sich
dafür einsetzen dass das
beitrittsverfahren sehr zügig vonstatten
geht die ratifikation durch die
bundesrepublik deutschland werden wir in
abstimmung mit den verfassungsorganen
unverzüglich durchführen wir laden
andere staaten ein das gleiche zu tun
andere wie die türkei das land ist seit
1952 nato mitglied der präsident
entdeckt nicht zum ersten mal seine
vetomacht recep tayyip erdogan wirft
schweden und finnland vor sie
unterstützten die als terrororganisation
eingestufte kurdische pkk
wie können wir ihnen trauen schweden ist
eine brutstätte für terrororganisationen
kurz kam möglich ist viele basis
funktionieren in der türkei und manchmal
nicht die mentalität vor allem von
erdogan ja auch sehr davon geprägt es
geht glaube ich riskiere es zusagen
nicht um die kurdenfrage in schweden und
finnland es geht um etwas anders
womöglich um diese us kampfjets die die
usa seit 2009 10 nicht mehr an die
türkei liefern weil erdogan regierung
damals ein russisches
raketenabwehrsystem kaufte unklar ob
erdogan sich die lieferung nun erpresst
oder ob er die gerade geeinte nato mit
einem veto ins mark trifft es würde
tatsächlich putin in die hände spielen
das würde das zeichen geben es gibt
keine einheit auf seiten der nato von
daher wäre das genau das falsche signal
zur falschen zeitpunkt es ist eine
historische zeitenwende für die nato und
den norden europas noch aber hängt sie
an einem seidenen faden aus der türkei
die verheerenden auswirkungen des
krieges auch auf menschen die weit ab
davon leben und versuchen zu überleben
kann man nicht oft genug thematisieren
und damit beginnst du jetzt hat ja laut
unicef hat der krieg in der ukraine
gravierende folgen für kinder weltweit
das problem der mangelernährung
verschärft sich wegen des gestiegenen
weizenpreise
lebensrettende medizinische
spezialnahrung werde deutlich teurer
deshalb könnten hunderttausende kinder
zusätzlich nicht mehr damit versorgt
werden schon jetzt sterben laut einem
heute veröffentlichten bericht des
kinderhilfswerks jedes jahr mehr als
eine million kinder an mangelernährung
nach den landtagswahlen in schleswig
holstein haben heute erste
sondierungsgespräche begonnen erst kamen
cdu und grüne zusammen am nachmittag
dann cdu und fdp morgen will
ministerpräsident günther mit seiner
partei darüber beraten günther strebt
eine fortsetzung des jamaika bündnisses
an und das obwohl er auch mit grünen
oder fdp allein regieren könnte
der vorstand der umstrittenen klima und
umwelt stiftung mecklenburg vorpommern
hat seinen rücktritt angekündigt laut
ministerpräsident in spe ich will der
vorstand rund um ex ministerpräsident
sellering ende september die ämter
niederlegen dadurch wird der weg frei
für eine auflösung der stiftung
schon lange steht diese in der kritik da
sie auch den bau der gaspipeline nord
stream 2 unterstützt hat
us-präsident beiden ist nach buffalo
gereist um mit den angehörigen der opfer
des rassistisch motivierten attentats zu
sprechen die tat sei ein akt des inlands
terrorismus erklärte beiden die
vergiftete ideologie einer weißen
vorherrschaft habe keinen platz in
amerika am vergangenen samstag erschoss
ein 18-jähriger weißer zehn menschen in
einem supermarkt drei weitere wurden
verletzt fast alle opfer waren schwarze
zu einer entscheidung die zündstoff
birgt die britische regierung hat ein
gesetz angekündigt mit dem sie handels
bei jedem zwischen großbritannien und
nordirland abbauen will die sonderregeln
waren im zuge der brh exit verhandlungen
im sogenannten nordirland protokoll
festgelegt worden um so eine harte
grenze zwischen nordirland und den eu
staat irland zu vermeiden als reaktion
auf die ankündigung drohte die eu mit
konsequenzen eine mögliche folge könnte
ein handelskrieg zwischen brüssel und
london sein
bei der parlamentswahl im libanon haben
die religiösen hardliner der
schiitischen hisbollah ihre mehrheit
verloren das reformlager sicherte sich
dagegen mehr sitze als erwartet eine
regierungsbildung werde bei diesem
ergebnis schwierig sagen beobachter
wegen korruption und mangelwirtschaft
steckt der libanon in einer schweren
wirtschaftskrise
es fehlt an benzin und lebensmitteln
strom gibt es oft nur wenige stunden am
tag
zurück nach deutschland der satz wahlen
werden gemeinsam gewonnen und gemeinsam
verloren hat gerade wieder
hochkonjunktur man kann verlässlich
davon ausgehen dass ihnen die
wahlverlierer immer dann rausholen wenn
die kritik an der eigenen rolle langsam
unangenehm wird
wahlen werden gemeinsam gewonnen und
gemeinsam verloren sagt tino kubala der
chef der afd nach der zehnten mal in
folge mit verlusten für seine partei am
sonntag in nrw ist sie gerade mal so
über die fünf-prozent-hürde gekommen
jetzt sind zopf und zank lange geradezu
ein markenzeichen der afg aber wieder
parteichef aus den eigenen reihen gerade
düpiert wird ist schon bemerkenswert
und wie er zurück teilt auch david
guetta hat jetzt über eine offene
führung schlacht und was das mit
campingurlaub zu tun hat
seit über zwei jahren kennen die balken
der afg an wahlabenden nur eine richtung
die afg mit deutlichen verlusten hf der
allierten
niederlagen in serie in ländern und im
bund seit tino keller parteichef ist in
schleswig holstein an der
fünf-prozent-hürde gescheitert im nrw
beinahe wieder deutliche verluste und so
liegt dieser tage rebellion in der
reichstags luft denke dass die
derzeitige spitze von fraktion und
partei
nicht für eine erfolgreiche politik
steht ich bin tatsächlich der meinung
dass aufgaben nicht gewachsen ist wenn
ein bundessprecher 10 wahlen in folge
verliert dann müssen wir uns gedanken
machen und dann steht dieser
bundessprecher tatsächlich für den
niedergang der partei wie groß der druck
auf den chef ist zeigt sich daran dass
seine co-fraktionschefin heute meint
fragen über die kritik an ihm abfangen
zu müssen ich lass mich der sonst
breitbeinig auftretende copala steht
daneben wie ein statist die schuld
allein dem bundessprecher
zuzuschieben das finde ich ungehörig das
finde ich
und kollegial und ich finde das auch
nicht stilsicher in seinem ganz eigenen
stil hatte kuba gestern noch selbst
innerparteiliche kritiker attackiert und
das ist wie früher beim camping ich
vergleiche das immer so haben sie immer
diejenigen beschwert dass es nass im
zelt sind ist und es waren diejenigen
die auch ein zelt hinein gepinkelt haben
das niveau der auseinandersetzung in der
selbsternannten alternativ in einem
monat einen neuen vorstand weltgruppe
will wieder antreten und über personal
und ihren russland kurs streitet seit
beginn des krieges wird aus der afg
heraus immer wieder putin propaganda
verbreitet der russische angriff
relativiert es darf in diesen dank aber
nicht unser ziel sein den einen
schuldigen auszumachen
[Musik]
die angriffe so
versuchen zivilbevölkerung ich beklage
von anfang an dass viele äußerungen aus
unserer partei dazu geeignet sind die
russische aggression in irgendeiner form
zu erklären bis hin zu entschuldigen das
massaker von butscher laut einiger auf
der politiker möglicherweise fingiert
und es den russen in die schuhe zu
schieben und immer wieder die amerikaner
als eigentliche hauptschuldiger
und jetzt haben sich über dieser
rechtsextreme björn röcke der einst
forderte der deutsche messe wolf nicht
scharf sein geriert sich nun als
friedenstaube ausgerechnet und auch er
liebäugelt öffentlich damit für den
bundesvorstand zu kandidieren
und wenn er gemeint er müsse als
bundessprecher antreten und wir hätten
eine einer spitze dann wird der gegen
kinox palla antreten müssen krupp aller
in die enge getrieben vom letzten
aufgebot verbliebener meuten jana auf
der einen und dem noch extremeren höcke
flügel auf der anderen seite entweder er
wird nun dazwischen zerrieben oder
bleibt als kleineres übel für beide
seiten doch irgendwie übrig
so und jetzt einen blick in die zukunft
auf den straßen dieses landes die heute
so irgendwie begann oder christian sich
im selbst fahrenden auto zurück lehnen
und entspannt ans ziel kommen das klang
lange wie ferne zukunftsmusik ist ab
heute in deutschland aber tatsächlich
möglich allerdings frank bethmann man
muss sagen mit einigen beschränkungen
welche das genau der vorerst nur bei
gutem wetter auf der autobahn auch nur
im stau und man darf dabei nicht
schneller als 60 stundenkilometer
unterwegs sein erst dann darf das auto
die kontrolle übernehmen dann können die
hände weg vom steuer film gucken lesen
sms-schreiben fast alles ist erlaubt der
fahrer darf nicht schlafen und muss so
ein zirka zehn sekunden wieder die
aufgabe übernehmen das level 3 system
fährt nicht in der baustelle oder bei
ungünstigen umgebungsbedingungen wie zb
schneeregen oder internat und es gibt
noch einen haken wie bei hochmoderner
technologie immer ist die am anfang sehr
teuer wird zunächst nur in absoluten top
modellen eingebaut unter 130.000 euro
ist das autonome fahren bei mercedes
noch nicht zu haben trotzdem ist das
natürlich heute einen quantensprung weil
das autonome fahren damit jetzt im
normalen straßenverkehr angekommen ist
deutschland ist jetzt erst mal vorreiter
wie weit unter die entwicklungen in
anderen ländern ja man hat ja immer im
ohr dass die usa nirgendwo mit ihren
großen technikkonzern wie tesla oder
google beim autonom fahren weiter wären
sind sie im prinzip auch denn dort
testet man bereits auf höheren stufen
das voll automatisierte fahren aber es
sind eben bislang nur tests in einzelnen
bundesstaaten deutschland darf sich
jetzt nicht auf diesen vorsprung
ausruhen autonomes fahren das ist
künstliche intelligenz da geht es jetzt
darum auch bei der verkehrsinfrastruktur
also bei ampeln bahnübergängen etc
weitere standards zu setzen standards
die dann nach amerika oder china wie
möglich exportiert werden können und
nicht umgekehrt vielen dank nach
frankfurt gerne
wegen betrugsvorwürfen und
milliardenschweren verlusten muss die
allianz in den usa milliarden zahlen
hintergrund sind vorwürfe gegen die
tochter allianz global investors anleger
über mögliche risiken eines fonds
getäuscht zu haben die us-börsenaufsicht
gab bekannt mehrere beschuldigte manager
wegen eines massiven betrugs komplotts
zur verantwortung zu ziehen sei
schadenersatz über mehrere milliarden
us-dollar fällig so die börsenaufsicht
allianz global investors dürfe außerdem
ihr us geschäft nicht mehr in der
bisherigen form weiterführen
die sogenannte bettensteuer auf private
hotelübernachtungen ist zulässig das hat
jetzt das bundesverfassungsgericht
entschieden mehrere hoteliers hatten
dagegen geklagt bisher erheben rund 50
deutsche städte und gemeinden die
bettensteuer künftig könnten nun noch
mehr kommunen dazu kommen und die abgabe
sogar auf geschäftsreisende ausweiten
der fußball-bundesligist tsg hoffenheim
hat sich von trainer sebastian hoeneß
getrennt damit reagiert der verein auf
den schwachen saison endspurt zuletzt
hatten die hoffenheimer nach neun
verlorenen spielen den einzug in den
europacup verpasst und wurde nur
tabellen-neunter es ist bereits der
vierte bundesliga chefcoach der nach
saisonende geht ein nachfolger wurde
noch nicht bekannt gegeben
dieses panorama ist immer filmreif auch
wenn gerade kein festival ist und
natürlich ist das setting die code ein
wichtiger grund dafür dass kann das
prestigeträchtigste und glamouröseste
filmfest der welt geworden ist und
bleibt auch mit 75 zum runden geburtstag
sind aber auch all die anderen zutaten
wieder da eine enorme bandbreite an
filmen natürlich viele stars politische
diskussionen und diese aura an einem
ganz besonderen ort zu sein aus kann
sabine schulz
als wäre die zeit stehen geblieben und
die welt wieder völlig in ordnung kann
wird 75 und alles ist wie früher
küsschen statt masken
gewagte dekolletés und große roben
mehr oder weniger bekannte gesichter
schon zur eröffnung die erste goldene
palme forest whitaker erhält sie für
sein lebenswerk vor 34 jahren habe kann
sein leben verändert sagt er bester
darsteller für die rolle als jazzmusiker
charlie parker im film bird von clint
eastwood
1988 gleich bei seinem ersten
festivalbesucher
das festival hat mir in der ganzen welt
respekt und anerkennung als künstler
verschafft das hat mich zutiefst berührt
kann ein sprungbrett zum erfolg für
generationen von schauspielern und
filmemachern
1946 beginnt was zum mythos werden
sollte sie werden alle kommen privat
porno entdeckt am strand von cannes vom
sexsymbol zur film legende
sophia loren auf der flucht vor
paparazzi
liz taylor kirk douglas die
unsterblichen ihrer epoche
grace kelly kommt mit alfred hitchcock
und geht mit fürst rainier von monaco
die wohl berühmteste kann romanze
[Musik]
1979 die erste goldene palme für
deutschland die blechtrommel von volker
schlöndorff fünf jahre später folgt wim
wenders mit paris texas und wird zum
dauergast und festival liebling
wir die üblichen verdächtigen hier im
festsaal verdanken dem festzug zum
großen teil und soll daher
kein wunder dass sie immer wieder kommen
an den ort wo es begann eine blutjunge
jodie foster mit robert de niro und
martin scorsese sie in cannes für taxi
driver
ich war damals zwölf mein leben als
schauspielerin hat hier in cannes
begonnen
es ist diese mischung aus kino kunst und
kult aus glamour business und skandalen
dicken zum weltereignis macht einer der
erfolgreichsten leinwandhelden hollywood
star tom cruise damals noch mit ehefrau
nicole kidman 30 jahre später wird in
und morgen wieder die korsett beehren
und seinen neuesten blockbuster bewerben
kann zwischen pop kultur kommerz und
großem kino
jurypräsident west london zum jubiläum
muss es ein franzose sein ein
stelldichein kann erprobter regisseure
darunter fünf goldene palme gewinne ein
vielversprechendes programm doch nicht
nur auf der leinwand wird sich spiegeln
das die welt noch nicht wieder in
ordnung ist offizielle russische
delegationen sind in cannes diesmal
nicht zugelassen
wie alles beim film ist auch der runde
geburtstag von kann im grunde eine art
illusion das festival ist dreimal
ausgefallen fand auch 1946 schon statt
da sind also einige rechenkünste nötig
um auf 75 zu kommen aber egal es klingt
gut sieht gut aus und wir sind ja im
kino und das altert sowieso nie
unsere gesellschaft wird immer
vielfältiger und darstellt auch die
polizei vor neue herausforderungen
polizistinnen und polizisten mit
migrationshintergrund sind dafür
besonders gefragt wie sieht ihre arbeit
aus die reportage 37 grad begleitet drei
von ihnen bunte polizei gleich nach uns
und sehr sehenswert und gegen
mitternacht gibt es dann unser
heute-journal update mit nazan charakter
mehr von uns allen hier an sie ein
angenehmer abend
[Musik]
guten abend morgen kommt das hoch wie
jannis klare server steve bleibt auf dem
atlantik die beiden aber haben was im
gepäck und das ist die richtig heiße
luft die startet über südwesteuropa und
breitet sich über frankreich bis zu uns
aus und das hat zur folge dass die
temperaturen morgen am ärmelkanal mit 30
grad genauso hoch legen wie hier am
bosporus 35 grad geht es morgen nicht
nur in tunesien sondern auch an der
algarve die temperaturen bei uns haben
ein großes west ost gefälle in der nacht
17 grad sind es aber wieder rein nur
sieben grad auf rügen
dazu ist es in norddeutschland stärker
bewölkt im süden dagegen häufig klar da
bildet sich auch mal nebel und morgen
die zu viel sonnenschein und meist nur
ganz kleine und harmlose quellwolken
über den mittelgebirgen allenfalls im
emsland können sie am abend mal ein
gewitter erleben vielleicht sehen sie
aber auch nur fairness wetterleuchten
und auch morgen gibt's nochmal große
unterschiede bei den temperaturen im
westen und südwesten wird es heiss mit
30 bis 31 grad im osten ist es bei 21
bis 25 grad doch deutlich besser zu
ertragen und dann kommt der donnerstag
und damit die schwül-warme gewitter luft
es drohen unwetter mit hagel platzregen
und sturmböen auch einzelne tornados
sind nicht ausgeschlossen diese gewitter
ziehen am freitag weiter nach osten am
samstag beruhigt sich die lage guten
abend